おおおおおおおおおおおおおお
はいもう大ケースも見ないだろうが分かりますの年まで来るんでしょ
お金もつですねハゲのメタ使いと末に住ん
それほど0時は終わってるよまぁ今回はもう見てわかるとおりここにねコーラが
ちょっと机所に出せなくて
ダンボールで6はっぽいてるんですけど120 l
おいであります面とシガー何個72個置いてるんですけど今日はなんとですねこれは
120リットルを使ってお風呂にコーラ風呂
作ってそこにメントス
メントスの体中につけてそのままコーラブルに入ります
a もったいないって馬鹿やろ
男なさ男人生一度きりだぜ夢叶えようぜ
別に夢じゃないんですけど4なんか外国の方がずれて同じようなことやってたねー
japanese 魂が覚えたというかねまぁ僕も負けずにね日本の強さ
侍ジャパンをね見せてやろうと思うんですよ
はい責任も浴槽の方に功労頭を移動させました
こんな感じです
メントスを全部出します中身を
ん
できましたマッツめっちゃ多い
はいそれでここからどうするかというとはまずから徐々に
そうだねうん同市目を体中にメントスをつけなければいけません
僕で考えたのは小浦免とセグハンド所爆発するのは炭酸のせいなんですよ僕がコーラン
をお風呂にいれた瞬間できるだけ早くお風呂に入りたいわけですって事は面倒でも体に
まとう時つけるように時間をとってたらもっといないんでこの透明なジェル派
テープでレッツチップ一句を貼り付けてこういう感じですこういうなんか
輪っかを作って麺とソックつけてこの状態
全部この状態にしておいておきますこうラズベリーたら速攻うー ducati むしろ
さっきやっていきましょう
ん
んんん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおお
ん
やばいちょっと1ないこれをあんなに気がしてきたというのでちょっと作戦変更です
ちょっと弁当に入れたらあーちょっと時間がなくなりそうなので先に
コーラブロウセットしますまず浴槽にボトルことを入れるまで入れておきます
もちろん愛ですよこの頃はいど寄付倒せば行けますちょっと口がある方が
波動反応した時に暑い中で泊すると思うんで柱リフト to do 安心してみて
くださいではこっち
裏お風呂に入れていきますあしらシャ行っている問題だ
メリダ元会長
米青子です
加須店
次次次次次次というふうに買えばいいかな理由付けしも注文その本辛い42
よし遊べますとよし全部ウォーター
相手よりだ今コーランの風呂ができたんでちょっと時間がね早く
目指すお肌でつけますエヴァ時間がない
時間どうぞばかりだん
ねぇ w
そういやば10ユーロああ
ああああああ
ええっこれでいきます
遠くこのこの感じで寝風呂に飛び込むと思う
色々と色々と山でもございますさんこれしてるかというと
by 初するときもあずよくわかんないとダメなんですよこういう細い2の1回圧迫さ
れないとこれは飛ばして圧迫部長います解放ています
bose 行くぞ
行くぞじゃあもいきますね3
まぁ適度はぁ
car
hey
どええええええっっそそそそっそこ
ぜひ
も良いををっ
a too
tes
3種
ダウンマナーまあこんなもんだってをたちと曲がってましたよ
そう